this is Wired's iphone application now
this is a nifty little app that works on
any iPhone or iPod touch it's a really
handy way to let you browse the
literally hundreds of product reviews
from wired com and from the editors of
Wired magazine now I'm going to show you
how it works once you've got it on your
iPhone just click on the wired logo on
your home screen and it brings up the
main application of the iphone app what
you've got on this screen is about a
dozen little icons representing
different product categories there's
everything from gaming hardware to
laptops two cell phones cameras and
camcorders there's even a category for
car reviews you can browse the products
by category just by tapping on one of
those icons you can scroll up and down
sorted by the name of the product by
default but if you want to sort it by
the latest so you see the most recent
reviews first you just click on the
latest button you can also sort by price
and by the reviewers rating say you are
looking for a review of a specific
product you can use the search function
right here you just tap the the little
magnifying glass icon and enter the name
of the product or the manufacturer that
you're interested in you'll get a list
of all the reviews that have that word
in their title once you get to a review
that you want to see just tap on it and
it brings up the review in detail at the
top you see the name of the product and
our official rating from one to ten
little blue balls as well as the price
and a nice big picture of the thing you
can scroll down and read the entire
review as it appeared on wired.com which
is often an extended version of the
review that appeared in the pages of
Wired magazine if you see a product that
you like and you want to share it with a
friend just click on the little envelope
icon on the bottom of the screen and you
can email it using the iphone's email
app so there it is Wired's iphone
application as I said it's free it's a
handy way to check on the official
lowdown authoritative reviews from the
editors of Wired magazine and wired com
and it doesn't cost a cent just go to
wired com / iPhone to get the details
and down
for free